détente comme simple abri de fortune
ils sont plusieurs centaines de migrants
bloqués vers les colis une petite ville
située dans le nord de la colombie
les autorités locales estiment que leur
présence entraîne un risque sanitaire
pour les habitants du fait de l'épidémie
de coronavirus et réclame un corridor
humanitaire à la frontière actuellement
fermée avec le panama en majorité
haïtiens un cubain ce millier de
personnes rêvent de rejoindre à tout
prix les états unis grâce à
l'intermédiaire de passeurs ce que nous
voulons c'est que s'il vous plaît
quelque part je ne sais pas une autorité
compétente écoute notre demande et
qu'elle facilite la vente de billets
afin que nous puissions traverser et
continuer notre odyssée la même
autorités colombiennes et le maire nous
disent pratiquement que nous devons
louer un bateau clandestin pour 400
dollars je ne veux pas faire ça avec mon
fils nous n'avons pas d'argent nous
travaillons pas ici nous vivons avec nos
économies les économies avec lesquels
nous devons faire le voyage
nous les dépenses ont encore et
maintenant nous n'avons plus rien le
golf du rabat est l'un des principaux
points de passage des migrants dont
certains viennent aussi parfois d'asie
pour rejoindre l'amérique du nord par la
mer des caraïbes
sept migrants sont morts noyés au début
de l'année lors du naufrage d'une
embarcation illégales dans la région
les migrants demande l'ouverture de la
frontière pour poursuivre leur voyage
mais ce n'est pas le moment de se
mobiliser au contraire c'est le moment
de se mettre à l'abri afin de minimiser
les risques de contagion ducobu de 10,9
la colombie a décrété la fermeture de
ses frontières terrestres et fluviales
le 16 mars 2020 une mesure prolongée
jusqu'au 1er mars prochain pour enrayer
la propagation du coronavirus